aujourd'hui je suis prête aujourd'hui je
pense que je suis une battante et que la
vérité sortira un jour de toute façon ce
nouveau combat judiciaire elle sera
seule dans sa famille à l'affronter la
grande soeur de marie angèle domèce
n'imaginais pas qu'un jour ce dossier
connaîtrait un tel rebondissement
pourtant c'est bien ce qui est arrivé
cette semaine michel fourniret affirme
aujourd'hui être le meurtrier de sa
soeur qui croit un petit peu parce que
il a quand même donné des détails donc
aujourd'hui je me dis qu'on a un petit
une petite lueur d'espoir la bataille
judiciaire dure depuis maintenant 30 ans
pour la famille d'aumetz dans la sphère
du meurtre de marie angèle le nom de
michel fourniret est évoqué pour la
première fois dans les années 2000 mais
chaque procès débouchera sur la même
issue le non lieu
désormais la famille le sait elle
croisera bientôt le chemin de michel
fourniret dans les tribunaux aujourd'hui
il va falloir porter plainte
donc la machine judiciaire va se
remettre en route ça fait peur très peur
même parce que on sait comment idée donc
il faut s'attendre à ça il est des
épreuves supplémentaires de nouvelles
épreuves judiciaires et de nouvelles
confrontations notamment avec les pouces
du tueur en série
monique olivier sa partenaire de crime m
ailier pour beaucoup de choses dans tout
ça quoi toutes les victimes ont été
prises par elle
donc ma haine en fait est plus féroce
son verre en verre monique olivier que
vers michel fourniret
cette nouvelle page judiciaire pourrait
résoudre un mystère vieux de trente ans
depuis 1988
jamais le corps de marie angèle domèce
n'a été retrouvé